Pittsburgh Steeler has had an eventful
offseason to say the least Le'Veon Bell
gone Antonio Brown gone and not a whole
lot to replace them Donte Moncrief the
new addition via free agency they
drafted Deante Johnson in round three
and the Steelers have shown over the
years and excellent ability to find
great receivers between between rounds
three and six and a lot of that I think
has to do with their quarterback Chris
yeah and yeah I think the most
significant development this offseason
given that REM Arthur's burger was
musing about retirement just a couple of
years ago he signs a two-year extension
he's under contract for three years
Kevin covert the GM of the team told us
that there's no expiration date on Ben
Roethlisberger and I think they want to
keep him around as long as he physically
can play because they know what it's
like to not have Ben Roethlisberger it
was a long 20 years between Terry
Bradshaw and Ben Roethlisberger and they
do not want to go back to those days of
a revolving door groping and searching
and hoping and maybe we find a
quarterback somewhere they love having
that franchise guy and I think we need
to started yeah I know there are other
issues callin players out that's not a
good look but when it comes time to play
and all the football accurately he can
do it unlike few others see yes I mean
yeah I know I take a lot of flack
sometimes cuz I think I say he's
borderline you know top 10 quarterback
of all time I mean hey he's been playing
football for 15 years he got he's gotten
to the playoffs for 10 out of those 15
years you know he's gone through teams
with different receivers different
running back to no pass protection
they're in the 2000 7 8 9 10 seasons and
it still didn't matter Big Ben and
company were dangerous as hell you know
I just look at all that and yeah I think
Big Ben Roethlisberger is still a
phenomenal football player but he does
make a few head-scratching mistakes
every year to where we go come on a year
15 you shouldn't do that anymore like
the end of the Denver game or the
Patriots game two years ago but I think
the Antonio Brown situation of course is
where you start it how can they replace
him right you talked about some of the
names hey this is a Pittsburgh Steelers
team that's phenomenal it really is when
you look at the roster there's not a lot
of weak spots there's really not and you
look at wide receiver and go gosh no
more Antonio Brown but hey juju Smith
Shuster
let's not forget led the team in
receiving you mentioned Donte Moncrief
Moncrief think that's a great signing
the the third round picked Deante
Johnson who you also mentioned Mike he
was one of my you know favorite
receivers in the draft he's a guy that
is ready to go right away I think he is
NFL polished good route runner can make
plays happen after the catch you
mentioned it they have an eye for
scouting wide receiver position
it'll be James Washington's second year
but I really think they're gonna be okay
on offense regardless whether Antonio
Brown or Le'Veon Bell are not there I
still think it's gonna be one of the
better ones in the league and the only
issue I had on defense was that middle
linebacker spot and they made the big
trade for Devin Bush they signed a Marc
Baron and free agency so I think that
can help out a position of weakness for
them this year traded up 10 spots from
20 to 10 to get Devin Bush and the last
time they traded up for a defensive guy
in round one it was Troy Polamalu so
they find the guys they want and they go
get them
Devin Bush already showing signs of
promise as that replacement for Ryan
shazier one of the things that Kevin
Cole Byrd has admitted they didn't do
enough last year to address that loss of
shazier was not countered by the things
they did in the offseason Chris back to
the receiver position yeah there was
something Ben Roethlisberger said
earlier this week when he had that
interview with kdka-tv in Pittsburgh and
he was explaining what he really meant
when he called out Antonio Brown for
flattening his route right when
Roethlisberger threw the ball right into
the awaiting arms of the Denver
defensive lineman he said look this is
part of the reality Antonio Brown is
constantly double and triple-teamed what
I really meant was I should have thrown
it to juju Smith Shuster because he was
single covered so now that Browns gone
it's miss Shuster even gonna be single
covered anymore right he's gonna be the
guy that they take away is he gonna be
able to still get open when he's getting
the Antonio Brown treatment from
defenses yeah he will be
I mean first off it's a pretty creative
offense they do a good job of you know
finding ways to even get Antonio Brown
the ball the last few years when teams
were trying to take him away but I think
the big thing is Mike for me is they do
have enough on offense still that's you
know if you put too many eggs into the
let's stop the juju Smiths Shuster you
know game play
all the plays that are associated for
him within that offense you know I look
at it and still go yeah guys like Dante
my mom cry Moncrief excuse me Eli Rogers
Vance McDonald at you know tight end I
think he's one of the better tight ends
in football right now and you talk about
again James Conner Jalen Samuel running
back they find ways to get them infused
in the pass game as well so they just
gotta find the formula that works and I
think ultimately the guys you're gonna
see on the field at wide receiver for
them more than any will be Moncrief juju
Smith Schuster and I think you're gonna
see Dante Johnson the guy that works the
slot is gonna be kind of the yards after
catch type guy and remember James
Washington a receiver they draft second
round in 2018 he was a disappointment
last year but it's hard to do much when
you've got an Antonio Brown introduced
miss Schuster they need him to step up
in 2019 you mentioned running back you
know half James Conner - half Jalen
Salmons they added Benny Snell fry and
tuck in some of the things he said at
rookie minicamp it tells me he's gonna
resonate with that fan base and Kevin
Kolbert made it clear they're not
looking for a revolving door of running
backs necessarily if there's a guy who
emerges he's gonna become the guy so
you've got Connor Samuels and Snell all
in that competition to prove that they
can be the guy they were spoiled by
Le'Veon Bell where you could go with
that workhorse and yes they want to have
depth now they want to be protected
against another Le'Veon Bell type of a
holdout and defection but Snell is a guy
who fascinates me round four yeah when
you've got a couple of good running
backs already and you use pick number
122 on a running back that's a position
where you can find guys in any round or
after the draft is over that tells me
they see something there with Benny
Snell and he's a guy to keep an eye on
as you know they put the pads on in July
and and we start to see who's gonna earn
those reps when it's time to play the
game yeah a little bowling ball of a
running back him he's 510 225 got good
power you know didn't impress at the
combine that's I think probably one of
the reasons he was even that far down
the line regardless I think the
Pittsburgh Steelers look at it and go
hey running backs an important position
we know that James Connor you know last
year was his first year you know it was
really being the the workhorse and of
course he got hurt for a number of games
and wasn't able to play so you know they
want to have some insurance
he's there too and I think that's
probably how they look at jaylen Samuel
and Benny Snell as part of the rotation
and insurance in case something happens
to James Connor all right quick break
draft time next inspired by Juwan Howard
becoming the coach at Michigan best
homecomings in the NFL we'll do that
right after this I'm feeling
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports